yo le abrí la cabeza a un ciego
no lo hice pensar o reflexionar le abrí
la cabeza literalmente él venía tomado
de mi hombro no calculé que ocupaba un
espacio hacia el costado de mi cuerpo y
lo hice chocar contra un portón de rejas
5 puntos en la frente
me sentí en ese momento el peor profesor
del mundo la verdad no sabía cómo
pedirle perdón
por suerte el pulga era de esas personas
o es de esas personas que se toman las
cosas bastante bien y es el día de hoy
que sigue diciendo que yo fui el
entrenador que dejó la marca más
importante en su carrera
la verdad que cuando entré a trabajar al
instituto para ciegos me ha sorprendido
un montón de cosas un montón de cosas
que ellos hacían y yo no imaginaba que
podían hacer así en natación atletismo
joven al truco tomaba mate se los
llevaba en eso sino se quemaban
pero cuando vi que juegan al fútbol me
pareció increíble
tener una cancha de tierra con dos arcos
oxidados y redes rotas y los hijos que
van al instituto armado en su partido de
fútbol igual que el que hacía yo en el
potrero de la esquina de casa pero ahí
se juega sin ver
la pelota tenía un sonido para que
puedan localizarla había un guía que
ponían detrás del arco rival para saber
a dónde tenían que patear y se ponían un
antifaz había algunos chicos que tenían
un resto de visión para que estén todos
igual usaban ese antifaz
cuando entré un poquito en confianza con
ellos me animé a pedirles un antifaz me
lo puse y traté de jugar había jugar
fútbol toda mi vida me pareció más
increíble todavía a los 2 segundos ya no
sabía dónde estaba parado
en realidad no había estudiado educación
física porque me encantaba el alto
rendimiento había entrado a trabajar
allí de casualidad mi otro trabajo era
con la selección argentina de remo y
sentía que eso era lo mío acá me costaba
todo el doble
no me voy a olvidar nunca el primer día
quise hacer la entrada en calor del
equipo
y los puse frente a mí tenía toda la
experiencia de la selección de remo y
les dije bueno ahora todo el mundo abajo
hice esto cuando levanté la vista había
dos sentados tres acostados otros en
cuclillas
como hago para hacer lo mismo que estaba
haciendo allá acá
me costó bastante empecé a buscar
herramientas a aprender de ellos de los
profes que ya trabajaban con ellos
aprendí que no podía explicar una jugada
en un pizarrón como hace un técnico pero
si podía usar una bandeja de plástico
con tapitas para que me interpreten
atrás del tacto
aprendí que ellos también podían correr
en una pista de atletismo
si yo corría con ellos tomaba unas
horitas entonces empezamos a buscar
voluntarios que nos ayuden a correr con
ellos y me fue gustando y les fui
encontrando
el objetivo el sentido a la actividad
me costó al principio incómodo pero me
propuse superar esa incomodidad y llegó
un momento que fue de todos mis trabajos
el que más me apasiona
creo que fue ahí cuando me pregunté por
qué no podía mostrar nosotros también
con los ciegos un equipo de alto
rendimiento
claro faltaba la otra parte había que
ver que querían ellos los verdaderos
protagonistas de esta historia
no iban a alcanzar a las tres horas en
la canchita esa de tierra que sea un
fútbol había que entrenar de otra forma
empezamos a exigir y la respuesta fue
magnífica pedían más
entendí que ellos también se estaban
preguntando por qué no podían ser de
alto rendimiento
cuando nos sentimos preparados fuimos a
golpear las puertas del senado el centro
nacional de alto rendimiento que tenemos
aquí en este país
nos costó bastante que nos abran pero
nos costó bastante más que los otros
deportistas que ya entrenaban ahí nos
consideren pares en realidad aprestaba
en la cancha solamente cuando ningún
otro equipo la usaba giramos los gritos
no sabían todos que hacíamos allá
adentro
el mundial-2006 fue una bisagra en la
historia del equipo
era la primera vez que se hacían buenos
aires y era nuestra oportunidad de
mostrarle a los nuestros lo que veníamos
haciendo hace un tiempo
llegamos a la final veníamos creciendo
como equipo y en la final del otro lado
estaba brasil
había sido el mejor equipo del torneo
ganaba todos los partidos por goleadas
casi nadie confiaba en que nosotros
podríamos ganar ese partido
casi nadie menos nosotros
en la concentración en el vestuario en
cada entrenamiento
había olor a campeón
le juro que se lo existe yo lo sentí
varias veces con el equipo pero recuerdo
particularmente el día anterior a juárez
a final
la asociación del fútbol argentino nos
había abierto las puertas y estamos
concentrados en afa donde concentraba
verón higuaín mes y para nosotros era
sentimos una selección de verdad por
primera vez
en la charla técnica el día anterior
siete y media de la tarde
estábamos en el salón y un mosso golpea
la puerta interrumpiendo la charla
para proponernos ir a una iglesia nos
viene a invitar en una iglesia
se trató de disuadirlo diciéndole que no
era el mejor momento que lo dejemos para
otro para otro día y él insiste
diciéndome que por favor los deje llevar
a los chicos a la iglesia porque ese
dijo un pastor que hacía milagros
le pregunté con un poquito de miedo a
qué milagro se refería y muy suelto me
dijo profe
déjeme llevar el equipo de la iglesia
que cuando volvemos estoy seguro que la
mitad ve
se escuchó alguna carcajada porque
imagínense uno ciego y le están diciendo
eso yo no supe que responderle me quedé
callado se hizo un silencio un poquito
incómodo yo no quería hacernos sentir
mal porque él realmente creía que se
podía pasar
y me sacó de ese apuro uno de los
jugadores que se levantó y muy seguro le
dijo juan así llama al mozo cosa este
dijo que no es el mejor momento para ir
a la iglesia pero déjame claro que otra
cosa llegamos a la iglesia y yo cuando
volvemos estoy entre la mitad de los que
ve terry cago a trompadas porque mañana
no puedo jugar el partido
juanse fue pudiéndose y algo resignado
seguimos con el charla técnica
y esa noche cuando me fui a dormir
empecé a soñar en mi cabeza el partido
del día siguiente imaginar qué podía
pasar cómo vamos a jugar y ahí es donde
sentirse el ahora campeón que le digas
un ratito porque en ese momento yo sentí
que si el resto de los jugadores tenían
las mismas ganas que diego de jugar ese
partido no podíamos no ser campeones
el día siguiente y va a ser maravilloso
nos levantamos a las 9 de la mañana el
partido de las 7 de la tarde y nosotros
ya queríamos ir a jugar
salimos de afa y en el micro que estaba
lleno de banderas que la gente nos había
regalado veníamos charlando sobre el
partido y escuchar los bocinazos y
gritos de gente que nos decía vamos
murciélagos hoy dice el último día
último esfuerzo
los chicos me preguntaban nos conocen
saben que jugamos
había gente que iba al cenar siguiendo
el micro llegamos y nos encontramos con
un marco increíble y en el trayecto del
vestuario hacia la cancha yo venía
caminando con silvio tomado de mi hombro
y dándolo por suerte no había ningún
portón de rejas en el camino y cuando
llegamos a la cancha él me preguntaba
todo no se quería perder ni un detalle
entonces me decía contame qué ves
contarme quién está tocando esos bombos
y yo trataba de explicarle lo más
detalladamente posible que pasaba
entonces le decía mira está la tribuna
llena se quedó un montón de gente afuera
y luego celestes y blancos por toda la
cancha están abriendo una bandera
gigante de argentina que ocupa toda la
tribuna en un momento interrumpe y me
dice fíjate si ves una bandera que diga
san pedro
la ciudad de donde él vive empiezo a
buscar en la tribuna y por allá arriba
vio chiquitita blanca y pintada con un
aerosol negro una bandera que decía
silvio tu familia hito sampedro
presentes si lo digo y él me dice ahí
está mi vieja decirme por favor dónde
está que la quiero saludar
lo acomodó y con su brazo le indicó
dónde está la bandera y con sus dos
brazos del saludo hacia ese lugar si
levantan unas veinte treinta personas a
ovacionarlo
y cuando pasa esto pero como se
transforma en la cara como se emociona
obviamente me emocioné yo también pero
los dos segundos se me hizo un nudo en
la garganta
pero pues sentía la emoción de lo que
estaba pasando y la bronca y la angustia
y no pueda el ver todo esto
unos días después cuando lo charlé con
él y le conté lo que me había pasado él
me tranquilizó porque me dijo cosas que
a tranquilo yo los vi de otra forma pero
te juro que los vi a todos
empezó el partido no nos podíamos
quebrar
era la final la gente tenía que estar
así como ahora en silencio porque en el
fútbol deseos
el público tiene que hacer este silencio
para que escuchen la pelota
y había calentar solamente cuando el
partido estaba detenido eso sí faltando
ocho minutos para el final gritaron todo
lo que no habían quitado en 32 desde el
alma cuando el chico silvio la clavó en
el ángulo y gritaron ese gol
una forma increíble
si hoy van a cenar si pasan por la
puerta van a ver un cartel enorme con la
foto de los murciélagos
son una selección modelo del país todos
saben quiénes son en el senado y después
de haber ganado dos campeonatos del
mundo y dos medallas paralímpicas nadie
duda que son de alto rendimiento
tuve la suerte de entrenar este equipo
primero como preparador físico después
como director técnico durante 10 años la
sensación que me llevé o que tengo es
que recibí muchísimo más de lo que les
di
el año pasado me propusieron entrenar
otra selección la de power chair fútbol
es una selección argentina de chicos que
juegan al fútbol en sillas de ruedas
son sillas de ruedas motorizadas que
manejan con un joystick porque no tienen
fuerza en los brazos como para impulsar
una silla convencional disponen como un
paragolpes con una defensa la silla que
además de proteger sus pies les permite
patear la pelota
es la primera vez que ellos dejan de ser
espectadores para ser protagonistas la
primera vez que sus papás sus amigos sus
hermanos los pueden ir a ver jugar a
ellos
para mí es un nuevo desafío de vuelta a
la incomodidad la inseguridad de los
miedos que cuando empecé con los ciegos
si lo enfrentó con más experiencia creo
que por eso desde el primer día los
trató como deportistas dentro de la
cancha y tratando de ponerme en lugar de
ellos afuera sin ningún prejuicio porque
como se los trata naturalmente es como
mejor se sienten
los dos equipos juegan al fútbol era
algo impensado para ellos tuvieron que
adaptar las reglas para poder hacerlo
y rompió los dos equipos con una misma
regla precisamente la que decía que
ellos no podían jugar al fútbol
cuando uno los ve jugar no ve
discapacidad no hay competencia
el problema es cuando termine ese
partido y dejan la cancha y salen a
jugar nuestro partido en una sociedad
que establece reglas que los tienen muy
poco en cuenta que no los cuidan yo
aprendí del deporte que la discapacidad
depende en gran medida de las reglas de
juego por eso creo que si cambiamos
alguna de las reglas de nuestro partido
les podemos hacer la vida un poco más
fácil a ellos
todos sabemos que existen personas con
discapacidad las vemos a diario pero tal
vez al no tener un contacto directo con
ellas no somos conscientes de la
problemática que enfrentan día a día lo
que les cuesta subir a un colectivo
conseguir un trabajo bajaron subte y
cruzar una calle
es cierto que hay una mayor
responsabilidad social
en cuanto a respecto de la inclusión de
las personas con discapacidad
pero creo que no es suficiente todavía
creo que el cambio debe ser de cada uno
de nosotros primero dejando de lado la
indiferencia hacia ellos y después
respetando las reglas que si los tienen
en cuenta que son poquitas pero hay
yo le abrí la cabeza a un ciego al
pulgar
les puedo asegurar que estos dos equipos
también me abrieron a mí porque me
enseñaron sobre todo cómo hay que salir
a jugar cada partido en este hermoso
campeonato que es la vida gracias